grab a bag of cheetos and put on your
scabies helmets because we have arguably
one of the greatest superhero shows of
all time you late [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
peacemaker season one has come to an end
and i'm happy to announce it's been
picked up for a season 2 but this show
caught me completely by surprise ding
dong [ __ ] with surprisingly complex
characters fun easter eggs and even a
cameo from the justice league itself we
can officially confirm that aquaman
[ __ ] fish is cannon it's
not a rumor i don't believe it so in
this video we'll be looking at the
show's ending some of the details you
missed along the way and what this could
mean for season two if you were to tell
me the plot of peacemaker revolved
around stopping a giant jab of the hutt
type cow from producing a mysterious
amber liquid only butterfly-like aliens
who want to take over the world can
consume i'd probably say peace out
[ __ ] but james gunn is a master
of tone delicately balancing the
zaniness of the plot with characters who
are surprisingly grounded when they need
to be and that's where we start our
final episode aptly titled it's cow or
never leota adebayo tries to apologize
for betraying peacemaker she's been
secretly working for her mother task
force x leader amanda waller and planted
a diary in peacemaker's trailer framing
peacemaker as a mentally disturbed lone
shooter responsible for the glenn thai
massacre we saw in episode 5. adebayo
has struggled with balancing her mother
duty to her team and family life and it
seems no matter what she does it ends up
going wrong
[Music]
and peacemaker isn't ready to forgive at
least not yet he's got a lot on his mind
especially after killing his own father
last episode this death is actually
foreshadowed in the opening credits
which you obviously haven't been
skipping right check out who it cuts to
as peacemaker
shoots and that's how his dad dies a
gunshot to the head from peacemaker
himself as we'll see throughout the
episode peacemaker is haunted by his
father and this haunting was also
foreshadowed by his father whether or
not i kill you you'll never be able to
get the [ __ ] away
considering the final shot of the season
has his father in it it'll likely be a
major plot for peacemaker next season as
he deals with the literal ghosts of his
past peacemaker hasn't been able to let
go of the guilt he has for killing his
own brother as a child something that he
was forced to do by his overbearing
father it's this death that made
peacemaker vow to only kill in the name
of peace my brother died i made a vow
right the vow and he wanted kill i'd
kill for peace as adebayo points out
this vow has defined who peacemaker is a
vow that is rooted in trauma which she
retorts but stop letting that [ __ ]
define who you are the core of what
makes peacemaker who he is is defined by
the death of his brother it's the reason
why peacemaker is a bully to others and
doesn't have any meaningful friendships
being a bully is just part of his
personality what if he pushes people
away then he can never get hurt when he
loses someone a hurt he experienced when
he lost his brother everybody [ __ ]
hates you
this time you're a computer friend but
you push away like you push everybody
away in this way his bullying acts as a
protection mechanism and if he's going
to grow as a character he has to
overcome this trauma this is something
he partially overcomes when he kills his
father it's here peacemaker finally
states that it was his father
responsible for his brother's death not
him but there's a lot of baggage here
and with his father coming back as a
ghost next season we aren't quite done
with him and peacemakers passed now you
might be asking yourself why is adebayo
here on their last mission she betrayed
peacemaker well she's on her own
redemption arc she's realized that what
she did was wrong and that she was
merely used as a pawn by her own mother
that's why she goes against her mother
and holds a press conference exposing
task force x at the end of the episode
there's also this added element of
divine intervention in episode seven
adebayo sees an injured eagly hug
peacemaker something she thought was
[ __ ] when peacemaker told her
eagerly hugged him in episode one you
know he's so happy to see me today wrap
his wings around me and hug me an eagle
hugged you oh yeah yeah i call him
[ __ ] on that you don't want to
believe in miracles that's on you
adebayo takes this moment as a sign or
miracle if you will that she's on the
right path maybe it's a sign even so her
mother has still command over their
group and in a hail mary attempt she
calls her mother begging to get the
justice league to help after all if the
butterflies are able to successfully
teleport their giant liquid milking cow
they may never be able to find it again
so the team has to act quickly
thankfully vigilante has smuggled a few
of peacemaker's helmets two of which
come in handy this episode the sonic
boom helmet and human torpedo you may
remember the sonic boom helmet was used
all the way back in episode 1. if they
can get that helmet on the top of the
barn and activate it then maybe they can
create an explosion that will destroy
the cow for good and one of the things i
love about this show is that their plans
almost always backfire resulting in our
characters being put in even more
pressing dire and often comical
situations while peacemaker searches for
the helmet eagerly dropped we get our
first confirmation that his father will
reappear as a ghost i'm in your head
i'm the reason you kill
and the reason you can't sleep at night
but he disappears before anything can
really happen with the helmet acquired
it's up to economos to sneak in and
plant the helmet seeing as he's the only
one the butterflies wouldn't recognize
and he's almost caught when larry
fitzgibbon questions him about his
off-colored beard something peacemaker
has made fun of him for throughout the
entire season so they're both strong
yeah and we're supposed to get that just
by looking at this guy beard now we
haven't really gotten a deep look into
economos's character but it's just great
writing how something so frivolous as
the color of his beard can be boiled
down to him being uncomfortable in his
own body he thought it made him look
younger and
more handsome
[Music]
he never had a girlfriend so he thought
dying his beard might help so economos
nearly gets himself killed but is saved
when the sonic boom helmet is activated
for the butterflies the cow is their
only lifeline if they lose it they lose
their only source of food to stop the
butterflies all we have to do is kill
the cow without it they won't be able to
stay alive for more than a couple of
weeks the sonic boom helmet can store
about three or four blasts in one charge
which is just enough to start the cow
cave collapsing in on itself but it's
gonna take one final push to get the job
done now this is probably my favorite
action scene in the entire show and
maybe even any dc property to date the
team takes on the remaining butterflies
in an absolute bloodbath of a battle
where we get to see peacemaker use his
shield for the first time this season
vigilante and harcourt end up getting
shot while sophie song who has the
leader of the butterflies goff
controlling her body races to the cow if
our team is to succeed it'll be up to
economos and adebayo to get in on the
action hey what makes you think you can
do this
because i'm made for this [ __ ] adebayo
has finally found the confidence to do
what she couldn't do at the beginning of
the season to get into the fight and
kill if she has to if you remember back
to episode three she didn't have the
guts to kill anyone but now you can see
she's completely changed oh and economos
well he's a complete sack of potatoes
and ends up tripping and breaking his
leg it's completely random and funny but
at the same time allows adebayo to
complete her character arc on her own in
a complete twist it's goth who helps
peacemaker out of a pile of debris after
he fell down the cavern that's because
goff needs peacemaker in order to
teleport the cow the machine will only
work with three people two to man the
consoles and one to push the lever but
as peacemaker says the [ __ ] would i help
you goff believes that once he tells the
truth about their people he like judo
master will help them these aliens fled
a planet that became unlivable a planet
destroyed by their own ignorance and
inability to do what it takes to ensure
it's safe keeping so when they came to
earth the aliens saw that humanity was
on the same trajectory and needed to be
stopped just like peacemaker made a vow
to kill anyone that gets in the way of
peace the aliens have made a vow to kill
anyone that threatens the survival of
earth even if that means killing a vast
majority of humans everything that goth
says here is a comment on our society
today ignoring science in favor of
populist leaders donald trump supporters
and global warming valuing profit over
survival putting company profit before
the environment treating minor
inconveniences as assaults on your
freedom wearing masks during a pandemic
it was mern who disagreed with their
methods remember he too was a butterfly
and he believed the aliens had no right
to impose their will on humanity even if
it was for their own good if peacemaker
really believes his vow he'll join with
the butterflies and save humanity
fulfill your calling
be the peacemaker
join us in saving your planet but
peacemaker actually goes against his vow
remember it stated he'd do anything for
peace even if it means killing so you'd
think he'd signed with the aliens but
peacemaker has grown over the season
it's part of his character arc and in
one of the most badass moments of the
series he uses adebayo as a human
cannonball who torpedoes directly into
the butterfly he'll later question his
own decision saying did i just kill the
world
maybe
or maybe you just gave us a chance to
make our own choices instead of our bug
overlords peacemaker has chosen freedom
the freedom for us to make our own
choices the body of sophie is shot by
peacemaker and the butterfly goth
emerges from her mouth you might be
wondering why peacemaker doesn't kill
goff here and it's probably because he
didn't see the point in it with their
only food source dead it would only be a
matter of time before it died anyway
then why would he give goff some of the
leftover liquid he had stored in his
fridge at the end of the episode this
could be for a couple of reasons one
goth isn't a threat anymore and
peacemaker feels compassion for a
creature who ultimately was trying to
help humanity that is if you believe
goff wasn't lying second depending on
how much of that liquid was saved goth
could become an ally next season we have
this alien being who likely has
knowledge about technology beyond this
world that could come in handy for
peacemaker and his crew now we get to
one of the funnest moments in the entire
season a cameo from none other than the
justice league you'll notice that
superman and wonder woman are
silhouetted likely because it was either
too expensive or not within the schedule
to have both henry cavill and gal gadot
make an appearance but we do get this
fun interaction between the flash and
aquaman which was just the icing on the
cake of an already fantastic episode
it's pretty ironic that the first
episode of peacemaker starts in a
hospital and ends in one two here
peacemaker finally accepts adebayo's
apology and divulges that she's actually
his second best friend next to eagley
don't tell vigilante adebayo further
affirms her friendship to peacemaker and
the team by outing amanda waller and the
existence of task force x you might have
even noticed the charlton news van named
after the comic book company that
published the peacemaker comics until it
was bought by dc comics the harm adabayo
did via the planting of the diary is
undone here as it's revealed both he and
vigilante were deep undercover saving
the world from this alien force expect
your favorite busboy to return next
season of course amanda waller is
furious over her daughter's press
conference and the fallout from this
event will likely have implications for
next season there's no telling if waller
will play a bigger role next season or
who the main villain will be but judo
master's appearance at the end crying
while eating cheetos is a good
indication that he'll return whether
he'll continue as an antagonistic force
against peacemaker and his team remains
to be seen but i'm kinda liking the idea
of him eventually joining with them
meanwhile peacemaker has been waiting in
the hospital for days as harcourt
recovers from her injuries peacemaker
has gone from a guy who only wanted to
have sex with her to genuinely
developing feelings as the two of them
hold hands and for harcourt this is a
change too just look at her attitude
towards peacemaker in episode one i have
no interest in you other than your
ability to fight for us i wouldn't be
surprised if a romance between these two
is something explored in season 2. we'll
later see her learning to walk again so
expect her back to normal when that
season hits adebayo also comes home to
her wife yes the one she accidentally
showed her nudes to while on a mission
their marriage has been on the rocks
since adebayo's work kept getting in the
way so hopefully this is the start of
mending that relationship even economos
has come to embrace the friendships he's
made along the way keeping a photo of
him and the team as he undoubtedly works
away at his next masterful powerpoint
presentation i should also mention that
he's back at balrev prison the facility
used to contain meta-human criminals and
the base of operations for task force x
and the suicide squad in our final shot
we have peacemaker alongside goff and
his dead father even eagerly brings him
a dead animal a callback to something
he's done throughout the season it's a
pretty wtf ending for peacemaker as he
comes to the realization he's gonna have
to deal with a ghost of his dead father
i guess it's fitting then that the song
you can't kill my rock and roll by
swedish heavy metal band hardcore
superstar plays in the background it
seems peacemaker can't kill his father
or at least the figment of him that'll
be something for him to deal with in
season 2. but what did you think of
peacemaker of course i want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below and who
your favorite character is mine's judo
master thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember batman doesn't kill people
because he's a [ __ ]